la wii francis lalanne si on met
narcisse lalanne dans fort boyard c'est
le nom du personnage si vous avez dans
fort boyard et je te dire que c'était
très très drôle
les bus et ou pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelques jeunes bompas francis lec à
nous raconter francis est ce qu'on a eu
francis lalanne parler un arbre oui oui
toujours aux arbres ou parce je parle
pas comme je parle avec toi mais je
rentre en communication avec tout ce qui
est végétal le végétal est vivant mais
ils répondent parfois il faut en trop
comme un voile à aller regarder la
puissance l'énergie la force tellurique
qui émane de cet être vivant
moi mon inspiration je l'avais puisse
pas que dans ces espèces de gélatine qui
font appel un cerveau c'est là quoi ce
qui vient de la terre
[Applaudissements]
plusieurs centièmes en raison d'ailleurs
un des trucs pas très proche à hidalgo
c'est de couper trop d'arbres voilà le
beau merci bien c'était le moment mais
bon elle c'est vrai si vous avez une
perte d'énergie
vous mettez vous prenez ou serrer le
tronc et là vous sentez revigoré je suis
d'ailleurs j'ai une perte d'énergie non
vous savez que l'intelligence végétal
n'est plus à démontrer en quoi on a fait
des expériences en 66 parties
tu prends cinq plantes vertes d'accord
tu mets des capteurs sur les plantes tu
fais rentrer cinq personnes sur les cinq
personnes y en a une qui va massacrer
une des plantes vertes après les cinq
personnes ressortent
elles vont rentrer dans un ordre qui a
changé donc les capteurs ne bouge pas
mais quand la personne qui a massacré la
plante véran 30 tous les capteurs s'agit
comme ça c'est démontré d'ailleurs tu
veux et était énervé contre ceux qui
s'étaient moqués de toit par rapport à
ça regarde c'est pas si on faire un
petit catalogue de francis lalanne vu
par la mairie ce faire
faire des blaireaux sa fille tracy salam
sall aux arbres c'est un copain
alors
que le principal adversaire
en chocolat
j'en ai su user moi de vous déranger
une force celle là
sinon alors les gens qui voient là
francis serrés c'est une légende et
puante et lit il a toujours eu des coups
d'éclat ce bien sûr est ce qu'on t'a vu
faire une tribune chez patrick sabatier
contre les ronds de cuir tournant mais
tu veux que je te dise c'est même
d'actualité ce que tu sais déjà à
l'époque bien peur regarde la caméra qu
elle est là caméra à l'épaule à tous les
ronds de cuir tout vous ronds de cuir 4
derrière vos opéra derrière vos bureaux
à dépenser le fric des gens pareils a
pas que moi il ya plein de jeunes
compositeurs comme moi qui sont pas
morts qu'ils sont vivants etc ont besoin
d'endroits pour qu'on joue leur musique
et vous vous n'êtes même pas capable de
la lire
et eux ils l'ont écrite alors les
empêcher plus les empêchait plus de
jouer leur musique
[Applaudissements]